there's a Fox News Alert we are
following several major breaking stories
as Friday night now I know so many of
you have been very frustrated so of i
with our system of justice we watch
let's see Muller's witch-hunt that's
been playing out for two years day after
day a lot of people's lives have been
ruined over quote processed crimes just
because of their connection to President
Trump and I know you've been saying to
yourself well what about all of the
people that we know have been abusing
power committing real and serious crimes
Hillary Clinton's one we look at people
like McCabe and call me and straw and
page and many many more what about the
FISA abuses stripping Americans of their
constitutional rights what about the
ramp and conflicts of interest at some
of the highest levels at the DOJ FBI
tonight we have great news according to
my sources everything that we have been
revealing about the deep state for two
years will very soon result in major
serious ramifications we're going to
have a complete breakdown of all of this
coming up all right but first just
breaking a couple hours ago Jesse small
it has been indicted on 16 felony counts
for allegedly orchestrating an elaborate
poorly executed hate crime hopes if
found guilty he could face major prison
time we're gonna have more on this
breaking news throughout the show also
coming up tonight we have big breaking
news surrounding house Intel chair known
liar and known collaborator and
collusion himself involved in Adam
Schiff and his brand new best friend
Michael calm serious charges tonight
being made about Adam Schiff plus new
developments and the Democrats scary new
wave of anti-semitism bigotry and hate
we have a Hannity expose on crazy uncle
Joe Biden but we begin tonight breaking
news out of our Hannity watch on the
deep state what we're about to show you
this is only the beginning
buckle up thanks to a surprise move by
one very brave House Republican we now
have damning evidence surrounding
the corrupt unethical dishonest actions
of so many deep state actors over the
past three years the congressman is from
Georgia and his name is Doug Collins and
he released the full transcript of Bruce
ORS deposition and its contents are
shocking by the way there's going to be
a cascade of these depositions being
released now the deep state house of
cards mark my words it is beginning to
tumble down to give you some background
keep in mind Bruce or was once the
fourth highest ranking member of Obama's
Department of Justice he became a
conduit for the federal government's
Russia collusion investigation remember
his wife Nellie actually worked for
Christopher Steele she was working at
fusion GPS on the Clinton bought and
paid for anti-trump dossier and used her
husband's position to proliferate the
dossiers contents throughout the highest
levels of government that's contained in
this deposition and according to ords
testimony which is now completely public
Bruce or passed along a thumb drive from
his wife to the FBI so that Trump haters
like struck and page could have direct
access to Hillary Clinton's op research
and we also learned that both the FBI
and the Clinton campaign via fusion GPS
they were both paying Christopher Steele
for this so-called intelligence and we
know that Steele was being paid by a
Russian oligarch we've talked about him
Oleg Deripaska who had a grievance
against Paul Manafort over a business
deal gone wrong let me recap this so you
have to understand this steel was
getting paid by your FBI Hillary Clinton
and the DNC and a Russian oligarch
pretty good gig if you can get it but
that's not all
thanks to this transcript we now know
the Bruce or testified under oath about
meeting with fusion GPS founder and
Christopher Steele's boss Glenn Simpson
now this occurred during the 2016
campaign now Simpson he testified that
he didn't meet with Bruce or until after
the election
question is which one of these two guys
is lying now we also learn from this
deposition that or testified he notified
the FBI about his contacts with
Christopher Steele also during the 2016
election but according to a statement
from Adam Schiff who I think's the
biggest liar in Congress he claims that
Bruce or did not tell the FBI about his
contacts with Steele again until after
the election here we are again which one
is lying my money is on Schiff now
here's where it gets really important
Bruce or also testifies that he notified
the FBI of the dossiers extremely biased
source and Christopher Steele's personal
mission to stop Trump a big trump pater
on page 15 of the October 2016 FISA
application against Carter page it reads
the following the FBI was unaware of any
derogatory information pertaining to
Christopher Steele that's right the
problem is everybody in the FBI knew in
August of 2016 that dossier was tainted
that Hillary paid for it the DNC paid
for it call me McCabe he even briefed
Andrew Weissman who's Muller's pit bull
about this bias so literally the special
counsels office has been long aware of
the biased origins of the fake phony
Clinton DNC and apparently FBI and
Russian oligarch payments to Christopher
steel this is hugely important a detail
never provided to the FISA Court that's
called the conspiracy to commit fraud on
a court to spy on a trump campaign
associate denying that person his
constitutional rights and this being
done at the height of the 2016 election
so in other words they have purposely
withheld to the FISA Court conspiracy to
commit fraud plain and simple
information that was so relevant and it
became the bulk of the FISA application
now it doesn't end there
Christopher Steele testified under oath
in Great Britain under the threat of
perjury I don't know if any of this
dossier is true may
be 50/50 you know was just raw
intelligence in other words the author
of the dossier doesn't stand by the
dossier raw intelligence 50/50 does not
become the bulk of evidence to deny an
American citizen quarter page his
constitutional rights and get a FISA
warrant now thankfully Senator Lindsey
Graham has now reopened the Senate
investigation into Phi's abuse and we're
also waiting for Michael Horowitz the
inspector general's report on the same
and unlike the Democrats never-ending
witch-hunt this investigation centers
around real crimes with real evidence so
what I'm telling you is it's all now
beginning to cascade down it's time to
officially now pull the veil off the
deep state effort they try to steal an
election they had a favored candidate
Hillary Clinton they had somebody they
didn't like Donald Trump and literally
they wanted to alter the will of the
American people both before the election
and then undo of the the career of a
duly elected president this is abuse of
power we have never ever seen in the
history of this country we have a lot
more coming up now to turn to more
breaking news tonight about another deep
state bad actor now do you remember when
congressman Adam Schiff made such a big
deal when then house Intel committee
chair Devin Nunez went over to the White
House to review documents remember this
take a look the Chairman will need to
decide whether he is the chairman of an
independent investigation into conduct
which includes allegations of potential
coordination between the Trump campaign
and the Russians war he is going to act
as a surrogate of the White House
because he cannot do both and
unfortunately I think the actions of
today throw great doubt into the ability
of both the Chairman and the committee
to conduct the investigation the way it
ought to be conducted tonight I'm
calling for an investigation into Adam
Schiff he is in hot water after
orderly get this sending his staff to
New York City to meet with Michael Kohn
for over 10 hours memory testified only
7 hours prior to his hearings on Capitol
Hill 10 hours well that kind of reminds
me of the time Bill Clinton met with
Loretta Lynch on the tarmac during the
Department of Justice's investigation
they were about to rule on whether to
indict Hillary or not
remember Cohn also testified that they
went over and he reviewed topics with
chief himself something that congressman
denied again what is lying here which
one take a look what did you talk to mr.
Schiff about I spoke to mr. Schiff about
topics that were going to be raised at
the upcoming hearing the extent of my
contact was just inviting him to testify
and also trying to lay his concerns
about the president's threats against
him and his family talk about topics
that's like a teacher giving you the
questions to a test ahead of time staff
10 hours were they coaching this now
needs its own investigation what he did
with Michael Kohn would be called
witness tampering and it's not a first
for Adam Schiff in July of 2018
congressman Schiff actually met with
Fuzion GPS founder Glenn Simpson he says
accidentally his met ran into each other
in Aspen Colorado
while Simpson was a key witness in an
ongoing house collusion probe now the
pair denied talking about the
investigation they were they were just
socializing and let's not forget any
Henry's reporting from 2017 according to
Edie during a closed-door confidential
hearing with Donald Trump jr. remember
Schiff was spotted going in and out of
the hearing room over and over and over
again while at the very same time fake
news CNN was gaining access to what was
going on in real-time with Don juniors
testimony as it was happening care to
explain that mr. Schiff and who could
ever forget the time that shift was
caught on tape yes
Lutie with somebody that he thought was
a Russian to get dirt on President Trump
so it could impact America's electoral
process the thing that he says he's
investigating we got him on tape doing
it listen the nature of the compromise
well there were pictures of naked Trump
was made aware of the availability of
the compromising material yes of course
thank you very much we will be back in
touch with you through our staff to make
arrangements to obtain these materials
for our committee and for the FBI and I
appreciate your reaching out to us will
collusion with Russia naked pictures of
Donald Trump I'll have more flexibility
after the election
all right given the serious conflicts of
interest now allegations of witness
tampering collusion his constant line
apparently apparent leaking that needs
to be investigated
well Adam Schiff needs to hold himself
to the same standard that he held to
Devin Nunez and that would be recuse
himself from the Intel committee's
investigations immediately there now
needs to be an ethics investigation into
Adam Schiff and he needs to be held
accountable no wonder he doesn't want to
come on the show his actions over the
past two years represent every single
thing that is wrong with the sewer of
Washington DC these are now major
developments and remembers so much more
to come in terms of other depositions
302s the FISA warrant gang of eight it's
all coming out and people will be held
accountable all right we continue by the
way our very important Hannity watch on
the rise of anti-semitism and bigotry
inside the Democratic Party this has
been a really revealing and despicable
week as we speak an elected US member of
Congress is sitting on the all-powerful
Foreign Affairs Committee even after
suggesting quote evil Jews were
hypnotizing the world that Jewish money
is controlling our government and that
her colleagues have a dual loyalty to
Israel
which is anti-semitism and on the most
vile level this should shock the
conscience and alarm every single
American
apparently not those in the Democratic
Party a group of outspoken radical
socialists they are now pulling the
strings in the House of Representatives
is congresswoman Acacio Cortez
congresswoman to lead
congresswoman Omar apparently they're
head of the entire Democratic Party and
Nancy Pelosi is just speaker a name only
the rest of the Democrats are either
fear-mongering or in total agreement
they had an opportunity to condemn this
hate this bigotry this anti-semitism and
they didn't do it this week now by the
way that's why Pelosi is once again
making excuses for this bigoted
continued behavior of her colleagues
watch this I don't think our colleague
is an anti-semitic I think she has a
different experience in the use of words
doesn't understand that some of them are
fraught with meaning that she what
didn't realize there's no shortage of
prominent Democrats rushing to defend
Omar and as per usual congresswoman
Acacio Cortes leading the way get this
she actually you know who you just saw
at the beginning of the montage is
fundraising off of Omar's anti-semitism
begging for donations because pro-israel
groups are coming after her to leave in
Omar a new narrative that the Democratic
Party is anyone who calls out
congresswoman Omar's anti-semitism is
Islamophobic it's a disaster this is
really now a issue this country has to
deal with what you have that we have o
abortion after birth during the birthing
process a party that leans so far left
let's see no planes no cows highest
taxes ever and oh no cars oil or gas
President Obama is not liberal enough
congresswoman Omar actually went after
Obama today